along with a horror movie that might
keep you awake for five nights we've got
a new manga anime series a crime drama
film with a strong cast an Argentine
horror flick that certainly brings the
evil and a cool documentary about bong
junho's first ever movie it's all coming
up on this week's what to watch you must
be new security guard can I uh help you
officer have you met them
yet met
who them hitting theaters is the horror
mystery flick Five Nights at Freddy's
and the first and main reason to check
this one out I guess besides the fact
that it is spooky season is that it's
based on the popular video game of the
same name first released in 2014 it has
since expanded with nine main Series
games and six spin-off games plus
graphic novels regular novels short
stories and all the merch and that kind
of popularity is definitely a good sign
another reason to spend a night with
this movie is that much like the game it
centers around a nighttime security
guard at a now shuttered Pizza place
called Freddy Fazbear's Pizza as he
defends himself against cursed
animatronics in other words all your
worst Chuck-E-Cheese Nightmares come to
life a third reason to drop a few fives
at Five Nights at Freddy's is the cast
led by Josh Hutcherson of Hunger Games
Fame and also featuring Mary Stewart
Masterson and Matthew Lillard with the
latter bringing a little horror movie
street cred after starring in the
original scream and don't forget about
the animatronics aka the band Led by the
frontman Freddy Fazbear himself with
Chica the chicken and her Sid snack Mr
Cupcake a bunny named Nam Bonnie and the
red pirate fox named you guessed it foxy
a they seem kind of
[Music]
cute arriving on Netflix is the new
anime series Pluto this action adventure
show is based on an award-winning
Japanese manga series originally
published from 2003 to 2009 and based on
a story arc from the legendary 1950s and
60s series Astro Boy so in other words
this one has some epic history behind it
and that's a good reason to check it out
another reason is the story for Pluto
which follows a robot detective with a
human appearance who is trying to solve
a series of murders connected to the
world's seven most advanced and
potentially deadly robots a third reason
is that Pluto is part of a long line of
important works from Creator naoki osawa
he is considered to be one of the most
impactful artists in the history of
manga and has won numerous Awards
because of it and all you need is a
Netflix account to soak in some history
you're not going to make 100k this year
it's going to be more like
[Music]
600 also coming this week is the crime
drama film pain Hustlers look no further
than the great cast for the first reason
to give this movie a chance it stars
Emily blent Chris Evans Andy Garcia and
the always awesome Katherine Ohara which
is really quite the foresome another
reason you should be feeling pain
Hustlers is that's based on the popular
2022 book of the same name by Evan
Hughes it tells the story of a high
school dropout who gets a job with a
failing pharmaceutical company and ends
up in the middle of a criminal
conspiracy yikes interestingly and if
you need an off-the-wall third reason to
give this movie a try it was directed by
David Yates who's best known for
directing four Harry Potter films and
the three fantastic Beast movies dude
can do it
all
[Music]
creeping in a shudder this week is the
Argentine horror film when evil lurks
the movie is about two brothers in a
remote Village say no more am I right
horror FES okay no okay we'll keep going
who discover a demon infected man who is
about to give birth to evil itself you
heard that right of course their efforts
to get rid of the man backfire and all
hell breaks loose uh literally I think
that's the horrifying first reason to
lurk around the theater for this one but
another is it's already built a resume
of success the screenplay won a
runner-up prize at a big International
pitch event and an early screening of
the film while still in post production
won a prize in Buenos Iris and that was
all before a strong showing during its
Premiere at the Toronto International
Film Festival in September which led to
its current freshness at 98% on the
Tomato Meter with over 60 reviews and
Counting and that's your third reason to
see when evil
lurks
for hitting Netflix this week is the
documentary film yellow door 9s lowii
film club reason number one to check
this movie out is that it offers an
intimate look at the emergence of a
group of young film enthusiasts in the
early '90s in South Korea that included
Oscar winning parasite director bong
junho in fact bong is at the center of
the story about the yellow door
Collective that ga gathered one
Christmas in 1992 to celebrate his very
first movie a short film at its one and
only public screening that's the second
reason open this door a third is that
director Lee yuk Ray who was also a
member of yellow door looks beyond
bong's involvement and tells a greater
story around the formation of yellow
door and the many talented and great
minds that were involved it's almost
like you'll learn something and enjoy a
movie at the same time well that's it
five interesting and eclectic picks that
will make you better people for watching
or something like that be sure to let us
and your fellow viewers know in the
comments what you did check out whether
it was on this list or not remember to
check out Ron tomatoes.com for the
latest updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay
fresh